on this sunday night
the world's covid 19 caseload climbs to
new heights
more than 25 million confirmed cases as
the pandemic's epicenter moves east
and as students return to school our
team of medical experts is standing by
to answer your kovid 19 questions
there's definitely anxiety in those kids
who are going
in person but also remote learning
police in portland provide an update
after a pro-trump demonstration turned
deadly
and kite fright
video captures a close call for a little
girl in taiwan
after a kite festival took a terrifying
turn
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
jeff semple good evening and thank you
for joining us we begin tonight with
what appears to be a shift in the global
fight against covid 19.
the number of reported cases worldwide
just surpassed 25 million
with the u.s and brazil still topping
the grim
tally but as david aiken reports the
epicenter of the pandemic may soon be
shifting from the u.s
to india no country has had more
infections than the united states
the latest data compiled by johns
hopkins university shows that
the u.s easily leads the world in covet
19
cases and deaths as of sunday morning
nearly
6 million americans have been infected
and more than 180
000 have died brazil is second in the
world with more than 3.8 million cases
and more than 120 000 deaths india has
the third highest number of cases at
more than 3.5 million
and over 63 000 deaths the johns hopkins
data has canada
24th in the world with just under 130
000 cases
and more than 9 100 deaths india though
has recently seen case numbers surge
on sunday the country recorded 78
761 cases and that eclipsed
the all-time record globally for cases
in a single day
that had been set by the us in mid-july
everybody was was
uh you know you know was out there
without wearing a mask without any
social distancing without any sanitizers
basically just gay abandoned everybody
thought that everything is over and we
are back to square one
that is something that we should not
have allowed to have happen
despite india's surging case numbers
prime minister
narendra modi is pushing to get things
back to normal
underground train networks are about to
open and sports and religious events
will soon be allowed in a limited manner
and while non-essential travel to canada
is still banned
the frequency of canada india flights
recently increased that said all
travelers arriving in canada no matter
where they're from
must still quarantine for 14 days upon
their arrival
meanwhile the world health organization
said that with 25 million cases
worldwide
the official number is now at least five
times
the number of severe flu cases that are
recorded every year
and the continued global spread of the
virus is one reason why the canadian
government
extended border shutdowns and travel
restrictions
at least until the end of september
david aiken global news
ottawa and coming up later in the
program we'll tackle your questions
about covid19 including concerns about
kids heading back to school
our experts weigh in on stress face
shields and what to do if your child
develops symptoms the police shooting of
jacob blake in the united states last
week has sparked
outrage not only in america but right
around the world
[Music]
today in london hundreds took part in an
anti-racism rally
dubbed the million people march to show
their support for the black lives matter
movement
demonstrators lay down on a road outside
notting hill tube station
to block traffic and violent and at
times deadly protests have erupted
across the u.s as people demand justice
for jacob blake
and an end to police brutality this week
president trump will visit kenosha where
blake was shot
seven times by police trump is running
his re-election campaign on law and
order labeling protesters
thugs and as jennifer johnson reports
his visit is expected to add even more
fuel
to the fire
it's been a week of protest and anger
after a kenosha wisconsin police officer
was videoed
shooting 29 year old jacob blake in the
back seven times during an arrest
now the white house says president trump
will visit law enforcement officers in
kenosha
the first time he's visited a city in
turmoil after a police involved shooting
the president's on the side of law
enforcement and the rule of law and he's
been very consistent in that
on twitter sunday the president
repeatedly threatened to send in the
national guard to clamp down on
demonstrators
in portland overnight one person was
shot and killed during clashes between
protesters
and counter protesters as that city
faced unrest for the 94th night in a row
do you seriously wonder mr president
why this is the first time in decades
that america has seen this level of
violence
it's you who have created the hate in
the division
minneapolis was again hit with more
looting three months after george
floyd's death
protesters and d.c police clashed late
saturday
at the new black lives matter plaza
democrats are pointing the finger of
blame directly at the president
this is a time more now than
ever that we need to hear from the
president of the united states
but the chaos and the disorder and the
lawlessness that we
are currently seeing that's donald
trump's
america kenosha's mayor is appealing for
calm but says the protesters
need to be heard the concern is that
there is an issue of
fairness and equity in their minds
wisconsin's attorney general says
officers tried to stop blake with tasers
but couldn't mr blake acknowledged
subsequent to this incident that he had
a knife in his possession but no
explanation is stopping the anger over
racial inequity that has swept across
america
the white house hasn't said if the
president will meet with blake's family
in a further effort to defuse tensions
jennifer johnson global news
washington the toppling of a statue of
john a mcdonald in montreal is sparking
strong political reaction
from across the country it happened
yesterday during a defund the police
rally
protesters pulled down the monument of
canada's first prime minister
over his mistreatment of indigenous
people the statue's head
snapped right off and has since been
removed from the site quebec premier
francois lego tweeted vandalism has no
place in our democracy and the statue
must be restored
the incident even provoked an offer from
alberta premier jason kenney tweeting we
would be happy to receive the statue for
installation on the grounds
of alberta's legislature to belarus now
where defiant protesters took to the
streets for a third straight sunday
following the country's contentious
presidential election
tens of thousands marched in the capital
minsk despite
warnings from the government reports say
more than a hundred protesters were
arrested
and as mike armstrong reports the
crackdown comes as the president
received a birthday call
from his russian counterpart
tens of thousands of protesters streamed
into the streets of central minsk sunday
despite knowing the danger that could
mean
here is what that danger looked like
this video appears to show
plainclothes officers grabbing a
protester off the street
scuffling with the crowd and finally
driving away
a russian news agency is quoting the
belarusian interior ministry
as saying at least 125 people were
detained
[Music]
riot police were out in force greeted by
chance of
shame shame previous sunday marches have
been held at the city's
independence square that was cordoned
off this week
each entrance blocked by government
troops
a large crowd gathered instead at the
official residence of president
alexander lukashenko the man they want
to resign
this photo was released by lukashenko's
spokesman sunday
showing him carrying a weapon at
independent square now the show of force
came
on lukashenko's 66th birthday for the
occasion lukashenko did get a happy
birthday call
from russian leader vladimir putin a
call that included an invitation to
visit moscow
in the coming weeks mukeshenko has
struggled to control
protests and strikes since his august
9th reelection
critics say that vote was rigged but
putin has made it clear
russia is prepared to help
thursday the russian leader said he'd
been asked by belarus
to set up a reserve police force and
that it would be deployed
if necessary belarus is also
cracking down on journalists authorities
this weekend deported several foreign
reporters
including ap reuters and the bbc they've
also withdrawn the credentials from
several domestic journalists
that means if those belarusians continue
to report
they can be arrested lukashenko has
accused journalists of
inciting the protests against him
mike armstrong global news israeli prime
minister benjamin netanyahu is hinting
that more arab leaders are now in talks
to normalize relations with israel
following a deal with the united arab
emirates this weekend the uae
brought an end to its formal boycott of
israel opening the door
for tourism trade and other business
between the two countries
it's the latest step in an agreement
brokered by u.s president donald trump's
administration earlier this month
a delegation will fly to the gulf nation
tomorrow on board the first ever israeli
commercial flight from tel aviv
to abu dhabi joining that delegation
will be president trump's son-in-law and
advisor jared kushner
who met with netanyahu in jerusalem
while this peace agreement was thought
by many to be impossible
the stage is now set for even more over
the last three and a half years
a lot of people describe the state of
the middle east as hopeless
but what i've felt over the last couple
weeks is a new sense of optimism
and we must seize that optimism and we
must continue to push to make this
region
achieve the potential that it truly has
the deal was struck without the
participation of palestinians although
israel agreed to pause a planned
annexation of palestinian land in the
west bank
palestinian leaders view it as a setback
to ending israeli occupation
a signing ceremony for the deal is
expected to be held in washington next
month
egypt and jordan are the only arab
nations to have previously established
diplomatic relations with israel
coming up a dark case of deja vu meet
the jewish man
standing up for china's uighur muslim
minority
[Applause]
we'll take a look at this a scary scene
in taiwan today a three-year-old girl
was swept more than nine meters into the
air
after becoming entangled in the strings
of a large kite
the child was whipped around for a few
seconds before falling to the ground
several people rushed to help and
incredibly her parents say she was
shocked
but not physically hurt for years we've
heard allegations of china's oppression
and mass
incarceration of uyghur muslims the u.n
estimates that at least a million
members are being held against their
will in detention camps
which beijing insists are re-education
camps to fight extremism
but for one jewish man in britain the
allegations are all too reminiscent of
another dark chapter of history
redmond shannon has his story
a very british tuesday evening here
comes the rape
orthodox jew andrew and eight supporters
quietly protest
outside a branch of the chinese embassy
in london
staff inside keep a close eye when i saw
the
satellite images of the concentration
chat camps that the chinese
government can't hide i couldn't stay at
home anymore
i had to get up and uh and do something
and that's why i started protesting
andrew who doesn't want his surname used
began his twice weekly protests last
year
it's not about me it's about getting
these women and men and children out
standing in solidarity with at least one
million uyghur muslims detained in
western china
when i saw that he was coming on his own
here
i thought i can't sit at home and let
him protest
for human rights abuses that involve
people from my community andrew says
he's motivated
by history my wife's
grandparents were either gaster
auschwitz in the extermination camp
there or killed in the concentration
camp there
but never before except once in history
have millions of men
women and children being rounded up and
put in concentration camps
and we know how that ended and we said
never again
beijing says the camps are voluntary
education centers
used to counter islamic extremism it
denies allegations of torture
separating children from parents and
forced sterilization
don't listen to fake news don't listen
to fabrications mounting evidence though
triggered u.s
sanctions against china with calls for
countries like canada
to follow suit the reason that you know
many countries
are silenced and they're not taking any
action is again
like i repeatedly say it's china's money
roshan abbas's sister was put in a
detention center two years ago
she says what's happening is genocide a
term
not being used by western governments
anybody who's learnt history knows what
happened in the second world war
and there are so many similarities it
seems to be happening again
and we need to stop it andrew is
inviting others to
do something similar at chinese
embassies around the world
one evening at a time redmond shannon
global news
london the italian coast guard conducted
a rescue mission in the mediterranean
coming to the aid of a migrant rescue
vessel that was funded by the popular
street artist
banksy the boat which was carrying more
than 200 rescued migrants
put out a call for help saturday in a
series of tweets
after it became stranded at sea unable
to move due to overcrowding
eventually the italians and a ship from
a german charity arrived and transferred
the passengers to safety
banksy the secretive artist known for
his social commentary
funded the boat accusing european
authorities of ignoring distress calls
for migrants
at sea still ahead covet 19
and the classroom as students return to
school our team of medical experts is
taking your questions about parenting
in a pandemic
thousands of students in quebec returned
to the classroom last week
and many more will follow across the
country in the coming days and besides
notebooks and pencils
their school days may involve masks
cohorts
and a lot of added anxiety to help
students and parents prepare we are
joined now by dr
dina kulik a pediatrician and emergency
room physician in toronto
and dr shimi kang a psychiatrist based
in vancouver thank you both so much for
joining us
our first viewer question comes from
nicole
moza who asks do my children have to
stay home for two weeks
every time they get a cold or flu
symptoms to ensure it's not covid19
and do we as parents also have to miss
work for a couple of weeks so dr kulick
let's start with you
uh obviously the specific rules in that
regard depend on your exact school board
but what's your advice
i think the most conservative approach
would be to stay home for the next 14
days
anyone that's been exposed to that
person who has illness
the reason why for me is that we know
we're contagious for at least two weeks
once we're unwell and i think it's
impossible at the moment
to really know if your child's illness
or your illness is in fact coveted or
not because the test
is pretty imperfect i'm not sure it's
very reliable or accurate
in young people especially and so if you
have a negative test
i still wouldn't be making decisions
about return to school
based on that negative test instead i
think the conservative
right approach at the moment so that we
don't risk putting ourselves
in a second wave would be to stay home
for the next two weeks
right and dr kang over to you next any
advice for parents
on how to talk to their children about
anxieties they might have
when it comes to heading back to school
yes and there's definitely anxiety in
those kids who are going
in person but also remote learning
they're worried about being left behind
academically and social isolation those
going in person
of course have safety concerns so you
want to have age appropriate questions
in the sense and i always say start with
open
and cure being open and curious so
really just ask them what's on their
mind
they may have anxieties about all kinds
of things so that's a great place to
start
and then guide them towards some
practical problem solving some things
that you may foresee
whether it's wearing masks or staying
focused online
and then really build a community and
start asking them
and telling them that there are people
that they can also turn to within their
school environment so that they can
communicate their emotional concerns
all right thank you for that and don't
go anywhere we've got more questions for
you we got to take a quick break but
when we come back
students in some parts of the country
will be required to wear masks when they
return to school
but are face shields a viable option
we're answering more of your kovit 19
questions
after the break
welcome back since the start of the
pandemic global news has been taking
your questions about covid19
straight to the experts and we are
joined now by dr dina kulik who's a
pediatrician
and emergency room physician in toronto
and dr shimi kang
a psychiatrist based in vancouver thank
you both again for joining us
uh dr kulik let's go to you for this
next question that comes from wendy
mccarthy
particularly in a context where students
may be required to wear masks when they
return to the classroom
she's wondering if face shields will
provide adequate protection
we don't really know there hasn't been
any big studies that have shown that
they're as effective or less effective
but the idea behind a mask is that it
protects your sputum your mucus your
droplets from leaving your body
and going into the air to potentially
affect other people
so if the fat face mask goes very low or
the shield goes very low
theoretically you're a bit blocked but
what i've seen um in my practice and
even on the street is a lot of people
are wearing face shields that don't go
very low they might only go
to about here or they're you know moving
around etc so
we don't really know the answer whether
they're effective or not when your child
and you could
wear a mask that's what i would prefer
because it's closer to your face it's
going to
prevent more droplets from staying
towards you versus going out
into the air right good to know and
especially certainly a lot of parents
wondering if it's even realistic to
expect children young children to be
wearing masks for long periods of time
dr kang over to you for this next
question and especially
pertinent for students who will be doing
remote learning or parents who just
decide to keep their kids at home
how do you balance concerns for their
physical health and covid19
with concerns about the impact that
long-term isolation can have
on their mental health yeah so we're
certainly seeing
increased rates of loneliness we know
that in general even before the pandemic
anxiety social disconnection was an
issue
so really making it a priority
if you're on remote learning schedule it
into your day
social connection prefer technology that
has face and voice so we need to see
each other hear each other's voices
and have that uh really scheduled like
homework time
where you're connecting with people in a
meaningful way we want
social bonding going deeper than just
socializing
really important for the tween and teen
because their brains are
more sensitive to feelings of isolation
so really i know there's a lot to think
about right now
and academics is part of it but school
is very important to keep those social
connections
and make that a priority and dr kulick
last question to you and a quick one 30
seconds or less this is a common one
from grandparents who are now wondering
once their grandchildren return to
school
should they keep their distance i would
i would assume that if kids are going
back to school
they're not only being exposed to 15 or
20 or more kids in their group
they're exposed to their people that are
you know bringing their own illnesses
from their bubbles
they're the people that are higher risk
the grandparents so i would be trying to
keep the distance if you can
uh and that's a heartbreaker and
unfortunately we'll have to leave it
there dr dina kulik dr shimi kang
thank you both so much for joining us
thank you
and thank you for joining us that is
global national for this sunday i'm jeff
semple
tonight's your canada is campbell river
british columbia
if you'd like to share your canada with
us email your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
robin gill will be back here with you
tomorrow have a great night
you